>> AS PROTESTS CONTINUE ACROSS
IRAN, CNN HAS LEARNED THAT
AUTHORITIES ARE USING
TECHNOLOGY TO GAIN ACCESS TO
PROTEST RESULT BONES AND SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS.
GOVERNMENT HAS BEEN USING THIS
INFORMATION IS EVIDENCE TO
SUPPRESS, ARREST AND IN MANY
CASES PROSECUTE THEM.
FOR MORE, LET'S BRING IN CNN'S
KATIE POLGLASE WHO
WAS PART OF THIS EXCLUSIVE
INVESTIGATION.
SHE'S LIVE FROM LONDON.
SO GOOD TO SEE YOU, KATIE.
WHAT MORE CAN YOU TELL?
US >> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME,
LAILA.
I THINK WHAT WE'VE LEARNED FROM
THIS INVESTIGATION IS THAT
THERE ARE A VARIETY OF WAYS IN
WHICH THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT
MAYBE ACCESSING PEOPLES SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS.
WHAT WE CAN LEARN IS THAT IT'S
NOT ONLY PEOPLES VOTES.
AND ALSO ENCRYPTED PLATFORMS,
SUCH AS TELEGRAM.
WIDELY USED AMOUNTS ACTIVISTS
IN IRAN.
IT IS MAKING ACTIVISTS FEEL
WORRIED ABOUT THEIR SAFETY OF
THESE PLATFORMS.
THIS IS NOT JUST PHONE RECORDS.
IT'S ALSO PRIVATE CHATS, IN
SOME CASES, LOCATION OF THEIR
PHONE ON CERTAIN STREETS, ON
CERTAIN TIMES.
THERE IS STILL A LOT OF
UNANSWERED QUESTIONS THAT MAY
BE SOME OLD METHODS THAT
THEY'RE USING, SUCH AS
CONFISCATED DEVICES, FORCING
PEOPLE TO HAND OVER THEIR
PHONE.
WHAT IS CLEAR FROM THIS
INVESTIGATION IS THAT IT IS
HAPPENING.
THERE IS EVIDENCE THAT
ACTIVISTS DO NOT THINK THAT
THEIR CHATS ARE STILL PRIVATE.
WHEN THEY ARE HACKED, WHEN THEY
ARE ACCESS BY THE IRANIAN
GOVERNMENT, WHAT WE FOUND IS
THAT THE REPERCUSSIONS CAN BE
INCREDIBLY SEVERE.
HAVE A LISTEN TO WHAT WE FOUND.
>> MODI, REFLECTIVE, LIKE MANY
TEENAGERS, SHE CONSIDERED HER
INSTAGRAM PAGE A SAFE SPACE FOR
SELF EXPRESSION.
HER DEATH ON SEPTEMBER 20TH
DURING PROTESTS IN IRAN TURNED
HER INTO AN ICON.
ON HER INSTAGRAM PAGE INTO
OBLIQUE SLATE.
WHO DISABLED IT AND WHY BECAME
ANOTHER MYSTERY SURROUNDING
WHAT HAPPENED TO HER.
CNN HAD PREVIOUSLY REVEALED
EVIDENCE THAT SHE WAS DETAINED
AT THE PROTESTS SHORTLY AFTER
THIS VIDEO WAS FILMED.
BUT THE IRANIAN AUTHORITIES
ALWAYS DENIED ANY INVOLVEMENT
IN HER DISAPPEARANCE OR DEATH.
NOW, CNN CAN EXCLUSIVELY REVEAL
THE META INSTAGRAM'S PARENT
COMPANY INVESTIGATED HER
ACCOUNT AFTER SHE DISAPPEARED,
INCLUDING THEY THEMSELVES WERE
NOT INVOLVED IN DISABLING.
IN OTHER WORDS, IT WAS EITHER
SHE HERSELF OR SOMEONE WITH
ACCESS TO HER ACCOUNT THAT TOOK
IT DOWN.
AS RECENT REPORTING BY THE
INTERCEPT REVEALED, ERAS HIGHLY
SOPHISTICATED SYSTEM FOR PHONE
HACKING, IT RAISES THE QUESTION
OF OTHER THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM CAN KEEP ACCOUNTS
SECURE.
PROTESTS ERUPTED IN IRAN, SHE
BEGAN USING INSTAGRAM AS A
DIARY FOR HER ACTIVISM.
THIS ONLINE ACTIVITY MAY HAVE
ENDED UP WORKING AGAINST HER.
AFTER HER DEATH, THE IRANIAN
STATE BEGAN PUBLISHING EVIDENCE
LIKE THIS CCTV BUT URGE,
ATTEMPTING TO CLEAR THE SLAVE
ANY INVOLVEMENT IN HER DEATH.
FIRST THEY SAID SHE WAS PUSHED
FROM THIS BUILDING.
THAT SHE FELL FROM IT.
NEXT, THEY REFERENCED SUICIDAL
MESSAGES, DOCUMENTS EXTRACTED
FROM HER MOBILE AND INSTAGRAM
CONVERSATIONS.
IT WAS AN OPEN ACKNOWLEDGMENT
THAT THEY WERE ACCESSING HER
PHONE AND HER SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS.
SHE IS NOT ALONE.
A SLIMS ENGULFED THE NOTORIOUS
PRISON IN MID OCTOBER, INSIDE
WAS NUDGING, SHE WAS SHARING
POSTERS LIKE THESE ON TELEGRAM.
THEY CRAFTED SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM.
WE CHANGED HER NEIGHBOR HER
SAFETY.
HER WORDS ARE RED BY AN ACTOR.
>> I THINK THEY ALREADY HAD MY
TELEGRAM CHATS.
THEY OFTEN TALKED ABOUT IT.
THERE ARE CERTAIN PHOTOS.
I HAD SHARED RELATIVELY
POLITICAL PHOTOS.
THEY WOULD SHOW ME THE PHOTOS
FROM THAT TELEGRAM TO CLAIM I
WAS THE PERSON.
I KEPT DENYING IT.
>> THEY SAID THE IRANIAN
AUTHORITIES HAD OBTAINED THESE
CHAZ DESPITE NOT YET HAVING HER
PHONE.
SHE BELIEVES THEY HACKED HER
ACCOUNT AND SHE NOW FACES SIX
YEARS IN JAIL.
>> ONCE A, PRESENT AUTHORITIES
REACTED TO HER TELEGRAM
ACCOUNT.
SHE SAYS IT WAS TO SEE WHO
TRIED TO CONTACT HER AND REVEAL
THE NETWORK OF ACTIVISTS SHE
WAS IN TOUCH WITH THE SAME
TACTIC MIGHT HAVE BEEN USED IN
THE TELEGRAPH ACCOUNT.
AS WEEKS AFTER HER DEATH,
FRIENDS NOTICED HER ACCOUNTS
BACK ON LINE.
IT IS SPIRITUALLY AFTER.
HER FAMILY ARE STILL REELING
FROM HER DEATH.
ONE CLOSE FAMILY MEMBER TOLD
CNN, AUTHORITIES ARE STILL
REFUSING TO RETURN HER PHONE.
THEY RUN IN THE 30S HAVE NOT
RESPONDED TO CNN'S REQUEST FOR
COMMENT.
WHILE MEDICINE THEY COULDN'T
SHARE SPECIFICS ON HER ACCOUNT,
THEY CONFIRMED THEY DID NOT
ORIGINALLY DISABLE IT.
TELEGRAM TOLD'S CNN THAT IN
EVERY CASE THEY INVESTIGATED
THAT --
THE USER HAD UNWITTINGLY MADE
SUCH ACCESS POSSIBLE BY NOT
SENDING A TWO-STEP VERIFICATION
PASSWORD OR USING A MALICIOUS
AT IMPERSONATING TELEGRAM.
STILL, QUESTIONS REMAIN AS TO
WHETHER, MEDITATION, OTHER TECH
COMPANIES ARE DOING ALL THEY
CAN TO PROTECT THEIR USERS AS
THE WORLD MAKES UP TO
INCREASINGLY TECHS HAVE A WAYS
FOR REGIMES SUCH AS IRAN ARE
USING TO MONITOR AND HUNT DOWN
ACTIVISTS.
>> IT'S WORTH NOTING THAT
INSTAGRAM AND TELEGRAM ARE
HUGELY POPULAR IN AROUND.
BEFORE INSTAGRAM WAS PART OF
THE RECENT PROTESTS, 90% OF
IRANIANS USED INSTAGRAM.
THAT IS A POPULATION OF 86
MILLION.
THIS IS A HUGE NUMBER OF PEOPLE
THAT USE THESE PLATFORMS EVERY
DAY.
EVERY DAY FOR COMMUNICATION.
TRINKETS, IDEAS WITH EACH
OTHER.
IT'S ALSO INCREASINGLY BEING
USED FOR ACTIVISM.
WE'RE CONNECTING ACTIVISTS TO
EACH OTHER.
CONNECTING PROTESTS AND WHAT
TIME WHAT DAY.
IF THERE IS ANY INDICATION THAT
THESE PLATFORMS HAVE ACCESS BY
THE IRANIAN GOVERNMENT, MAY NOT
BE SECURE, THAT, IS OF COURSE,
INCREDIBLY CONCERNING.
THE QUESTION FOR THIS
INVESTIGATION IS WHETHER THE
TECH COMPANIES ARE WELL
EQUIPPED TO DEAL WITH THESE
CHALLENGES.
>> IMPORTANT QUESTIONS.
THANK YOU, KATIE, PRECEDED